hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay um I
accidentally skipped ahead a bit I
stopped I thought I started recording
and I didn't but and I got a little bit
ahead before I noticed but you didn't
miss anything
we're down in these sewers after I
jumped over the fence
I pushed two buttons and then I went
down in these sewers and this is where I
am I just dropped through a second hole
in the sewers to where I am now and
nothing happened so far oh hello well
yes this is not a ladder this is a rope
but well done
okay um okay can't get through here okay
up here huh huh huh huh ah oh he's a
treat Oh
ah okay another abandoned house it
should be should be good big cars pills
Oh me pills mm-hmm
mm-hmm huh
okay oh one six oh one six or nine 100
one six okay huh huh who's down here ha
ha ha ah oh yeah I bet I get regret ever
ever
Hey Baby hey baby baby I believe I won 6
aah
Oh God gotcha
wait no aah holy crap guys I want to die
what'd they do uh uh uh
fire axe ha ha oh I'll take this quicker
I like it quicker and I think it'd do
more damage than a hammer I like it
can't get out here no uh-uh no okay huh
battery yes I need battery real bad cuz
I don't want to run out of battery in
these woods
Oh anybody Oh
the gate back there ok
come on oh man these trees do not look
fun in the dark okay oh it's brightly
lit oh cool die oh my god oh my god oh
[ __ ] you what the oh god damn it how can
I miss like that where are you there you
are okay aunt just died
this one's extra tough I'm trying to peg
it in the head but with their head is so
small and twitchy sometimes that it's
almost impossible huh ah there you are
no oh come on
what's with the instant [ __ ] hell I
can't deal with that ah no no no get
away [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh man they take a lot of bullets to
bring down not fair
I'm out of shotgun shells what's in here
I'm probably a ring that I could've
stepped in to take care of the guy but I
didn't see it what the hell is this oh
wait oh go this way okay I see huh is
there ah not you are you kidding me huh
what's this oh it's a different gun oh
this is see this is the stronger gun
okay
they use the same bullets is just
stronger you just there we go yes I
don't know why I switch out for the
Glock so long ago but this is better
Wow huh ah there we go that's more like
it
too bad I already used up like all of my
bullets okay
I'm gonna run out of ammo here I'm
literally gonna run straight out of ammo
off [ __ ] hell miss Bok bonk
God oh I'm gonna have to deal with them
with some axe action you want some axe
huh let me ask you a question huh come
on now don't be like that
oh boy down here again oh boy here we go
oh that's why they gave me the pills so
I could survive that all right new level
Oh more shotgun ammo yes please only
four shells Oh give me a full aah
gave me a full clip ah mo it's like
they're loading me up for something oh
boy oh boy
maybe they're just being nice ah come on
back up back up what the hell ah okay
all right God just get on the okay come
whoa how'd you get there dodge dodge oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god ah
how do you get there
oh my god oh oh you you're next
ah oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy I don't
have enough ammo for this huh huh ah are
you so quick why are you so tough
take toughness lessons from me Oh God
they won't die ah ah Carter oh my god
come on die you son of a [ __ ]
oh my god they just don't die Oh Oh
where'd you go ah [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] hell
there finally oh my god fall over
[ __ ] I'm down to the axe oh I got
one down two down no come on oh I like
this ex I like this accident is that all
of them oh my god oh I made Christmas Oh
was there any like goodies on the other
liners I don't care this axe is good cuz
it's like quick and hits hard
oh oh this car
a little jumpy little jumpy Oh more
shotgun ammo batteries and pills good
good good good
wack and want some more pills yes please
and mo yes oh my god thank you thank you
oh crap I see something out there
I see it looks like a spider dude oh it
is a spider dude there's more than one
spire dude oh my god I'm gonna die I
don't have enough ammo maybe I can get
him on that this car here try it come
here come here come here on the car Oh
God on the car on the [ __ ] car you
gotta be [ __ ] me
okay where are they oh holy crap come
here
come here guy come here come here
came to see you come here there we go
yes yes come closer oh my god you're
like right there come on okay here we go
yes oh not an exploit eyes not an
exploit game mechanics okay come on come
closer come closer another one
come here oh my god it's got [ __ ] ah
damn it
I can I can get them without getting hit
I can do that
ah okay yes stay right there
oh my god there we go here we go
hook handled they gave me a car for a
reason it's dead heart we're good we're
good we're good
oh man it's locked I need to find
another way the woods somewhere
ah ah huh huh one more oh the car all
the car there you are buddy
come at me bro tell me come on come on
oh hello there yard all right come on
come on Harry Oh what the hell
there we go love ah if they hit if they
throw a spitter at me I'm gonna be
pissed and I'm gonna be dead too don't
know what's with this like playpen here
I get in here
maybe not through that way it doesn't
look like there's a way ah
be
good good Oh [ __ ] Oh goddamn it
huh oh not you oh oh
huh oh man huh that got me good oh man
oh wow oh wow I think I was supposed to
get closer the first time and let it you
know like you know it was just was a
booming but the fact that I looked at it
and thought it was an enemy and then it
suddenly was like oh ah come here
dick dick this shotgun is not powerful
not powerful at all Oh what is that a
fire fires well why did I have to crash
my car in the woods oh my god
nothing over here anything on the ground
was there anything in here was the point
in doing this
maybe oh I see it's two separate ah
gotcha so that's where I first went I
need to go this way
aha
Oh oh boy oh boy where Greg take out I
can take yeah ah come here huh
come on yes all right I can take him
down I can do this there's another one
aha OOP [ __ ] Gabriel there we go
come on come on at me bro come at me bro
nope not to die all [ __ ] got ya okay
let's two down two down no mo
two down okay and bro ah pro and pro
I'll [ __ ] pro bro there we go yes I love
this axe I've been slowly progressively
getting better and better
melee weapons ah one more I saw you why
did it have to be a cemetery whoa you're
you're a speedy one aren't you you're
speedy one not speedy enough there we go
it's quick to instant response not like
the hammer with the long wind-up oh whoa
another one
oh [ __ ] was that a metal tree ah ah yeah
yeah yeah oh no yeah yeah yeah there we
go
four or five hits whoo okay I'm doing
good I'm making progress
moving instant kill boxes yes box mo oh
another gun this looks like a Beretta
don't want the bread or the wait where'd
the other one go oh it's in there I
think I'll keep this one it's only two
less bullets and oh well I get no ammo
so I guess I'm taking this one then aah
oh no aah
you gotta be oh wait hold on mother of
[ __ ] you gotta be joking me you gotta
be kidding me
with up you a [ __ ] hell all right I
guess I'm not getting that okay that's
all the time I got for this episode
thank you guys so much for watching as
always I appreciate every single one of
you and I will see you in the next part
bye-bye